[음악]
현지 부동산 하시는 분이 이제 좀 뭐
부동산 투어가 좀 예정되어 있어
가지고 좀 아침에 일단 픽업 오신다
그래서 좀 기다리고 있는 상황입니다
아직 그 정도 단게 아니고 제가
알아야 될 거 같아요 제가 일단 어느
정도 알고 좀 검증도 되고 한국분들이
찾는다고 하면은 일단은 테스트로 이제
좀 협력으로 계속 했다가 나아가서는
진짜 만약에 괜찮다라고 하면 뭐 차례
생각도 있긴 합니다 실제로 매물도 좀
보여 달라고 요청을 했고 그래서 그
매물 투어도 좀 같이 할 예정이고
그리고 중간중간에 좀 이렇게 일본
부동산에 대해서 인터뷰를 좀 진행할
예정인데 한국분들이 좀 일본 부동산을
매입하는데 있어서 좀 많은 도움을
주시지 않을까 그렇게 예상하고
있습니다
최근에 되게 많이 이슈가 있잖아요
일본이 금리도 그렇고 엔도 좀 낮은
수준이라서 그런 기회 비용을 좀
이쪽에서 이렇게 하시려고 하시는 거
같더라고요 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다
어 제가 오늘 도쿄에서 제일 핫한
아자드 앞에 와 있는데 오늘 일단
부동산 투어를 해 주실 어 저희 조
대표님을 모셨습니다 안녕하세요네
안녕하세요 처 인사드리겠습니다 주리얼
에스테이트 조민 스러 갑니다 실제로
오늘 좀 처음 뵙는데 일단 인상도
너무 좋으시고 또 이제 한국분들이
일본 부동산 투자한다고 할 때 좀
도움을 좀 많이 주셨어요 경험도 좀
많으시고 고객분들이 많이 물어보세요
지금 아자즈 대해서 좀 간단하게 설명
좀 해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 토지
수용하는데만 약 한 30년 정도
걸렸다고 합니다 실제로 이제 개발하는
데는 한 3년에서 4년 정도 걸렸던
거 같습니다 저 도쿄에서 가장 높은
건물이고 그리고 한 64층 건물인데
실제로도 한 연면적 한 22만 평
정도 되는 이제 대규모 빌딩
건물입니다 이거는 지금 제일 비싼 건
얼마 정 아 뭐 펜트하우스가 얼마
전에 뉴스에 나왔던 거지만 한
200억엔 그러니까 한국 돈으로 치면
한 2억이 넘는 수준이라고 얘기를
제가 뉴스로도 보도가 된 걸
확인했습니다 2천억 정도 되는데도 살
사람들이 꽤 많다는 거죠 예 그렇죠
이게 이제 공개 분양이 아니고 이제
비공개식이구
진행이 되는 거 같고요 실제로 대기
인형만 제가 알고 있는 것만 한
200명 정도라는 것을 제가 좀
얘기를 들었습니다 건물이 뒤에 가려져
있 안 보이는데 레지던스 동이 따로
있어요 기존에 토지를 가지고 있던
분들이 저기 분양권을 받을 수 있지
않습니까 그 분양권을 받아서 시장에
내놓는데 제가 작년만에도 평당 한
1,500만 원 수준에서도 거래가
됐었던 걸 지금은 한 2500만
엔에서 3,500만 원까지도 나오는
물건이 있습니다 그러니까 한국선
치면은 이제 아까 말씀드렸던 10대
1 기준으로 한다고 하면 평당 한
2억 5천에서 3억 5천 정도
그런데도 불구하고 2억 5천
수준이라고 한다고 하면은 뭐 물건이
나오자마자 나간다고
하더라고 그래서 이게 자료로 봤던
건물인데 실제로 와서 보니까 되게
좋네요 그죠 이게 실제로 여기 쭉
올라가면은 이제 하라주 그라는 곳이고
3월에 이제 처음에 나왔던게 17억
6천만에 세금 포함이요 근데 이게
3월 달에 성역이 되고 나서 7월에
다시 한번 나왔는데 그게 세금 포함
21억 엔 2억 근데 그 21억 엔도
나온지 한 달도 안 돼서 성약이 된
걸로 그리고 한국에서 혹은 해외
관광객들이 오면은 지나가는 필스
거리입니다 그래서 쭉 아까 말씀드려
올라가면은 이제 다케시다
토이라이더 바로 이쪽 길로 지나가면은
이제 캐스트하는 또 거리가 연결되는
그래서 하라주쿠에 오면은 누구나
이렇게 통과하는 거리 중에 한
루트라고 생각하셔도 되죠 그 예 아
아 어떤 맛 제가 술을 잘 먹지
못하지만 이게 되게 잘 잘 넘어요
괜찮아요 아 다행 일본의 그 중계
수술은 는 만약에 양측에 중계를 하는
중개업자 한다고 하면은 청구할 수
있는 대상이 매도자와 매수자 양적으로
청구할 수가 있고 이때 청구되는
금액은 매매대금에서 3% 법인의
경우에는 이제 매매대금에서 소비세를
제외한 3% 플스 6만이 이제
중개수수료 그리고 마지막으로 또이
금액에서 서비스 10% 해야지 전개
수수료 대출 금리가 한 느 정도
될까요 외국인 분들이라고 특별하게
별이 있거나 되는 금리가 다르진
않고요 통 적게는 1.8% 어 많게는
뭐 2% 후반까지도 있으나 다행히도
신화 은행이나 이런 한국 은행이 있기
때문에 2% 전으로 가능하지 않을까
생각됩니다 그리고 한국 투자자분들이
주로 좀 어디에 투자하는지 궁금합니다
보통 이제 이렇게 크게 나뉘는 거는
야마노테 선이라는 일본에서도 가장
많이 이용하는 선 중에 하나인데 그
내부를 그 안쪽을 보통 투자 대상지로
보고 도심 5구 5구 내가 일반적이고
그중에서도 또 3구 이렇게 보시는
분들도 많습니다 도심 오구라는 거는
이제 치오 아쿠 미나토구네 치 오쿠가
이제 도쿄 3구에 하고요 나머지 두
구가 시부야 신즈 이렇게 해서 도심
5구가 됩니다 안쪽에서 보는 것이
가장 안전하고 그리고 실제 실세
차익도 많이 느릴 수 있지 않을까
이렇게 생각됩니다 그래서 약간 한국
사람들이 살 때 이제 그냥 a z
있지 좀 말씀해 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다 첫 번째로 대출이 확인이
가능한지 은행에 확인을 하고 두
번째로 대출이 가능하다라고 하면은
이제 법인을 설립을 하시고에 법인이
설립을 하면은 이제 물건을 보시면
되는데 혹은 한 달 반에서 한 두 달
정도 생각하시는게 좋을 것 같습니다
물건을 실제로 인도 받으면 그 건물을
일본 같은 경우는 관리를 해야 되는데
관리를 당사 측에서도 지금 운영하고
있어서 관리도 일괄로 저희가 원스톱
대응해 드리고 있고 향후 매각은 물론
또 법인도 설립을 되어 있으니이
법인을 운영하게 되면 결산서를
필요하지 않습니까 그런 이제 세무적인
업무도 방사가 제외되어 있는 리사를
통해서 그런 부분들도 다 한국어로
대응할 수 있게끔 안내해 드리고
있습니다 처음 물건 살 때부터 내각
하실 때까지 일과로 다
안내해드리겠습니다 좀 민감한 질문인데
관리 수수료는 얼마 정도 될까요
임대료의 5% 임대료의 5% 저희가
수정하고 있습니다 일단은 오늘 영상은
여기까지고 그리고 혹시 만약에
궁금한게 있으시다고 하면 저희가 이제
유튜브 창에 제가 좀 띄어 놓을테니까
뭐 그런 거 통해서 물어보셔도 좋을
거 같고 그리고 혹시 저희 채널 보고
연락드렸다고 하면은 좀 잘 챙겨
주세요 아 예
론네 뭐 일본 부동산 궁금한 거
있으시면 언제든지 저희 조 대표님한테
연락 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다 여기 여기
카메라 보시면 될 거 같아요네
[음악]
안녕히계세요네